what's today's video about what you've
got here matt so
this is the handwritten results from a
mathematician who lived in the mid to
late 1800s a gentleman called william
shanks who i think in the modern day we
would call a recreational mathematician
he had a real job ran a boarding school
in his spare time he just did
calculation after calculation william
sent all of his incredible results into
the royal society here we go so this is
w shanks reciprocals of prime numbers
and then what follows is and these are
the sections and when he did him so you
can see he's got them in batches of ten
to five thousand at a time and this is
across years this was not a fast process
and then
here's what he found and he describes it
here and the left-hand columns of this
table are primes these are the prime
numbers down here in the right-hand
columns is the number of figures in the
period of the reciprocal of each prime
so what he's done is he's taken each
prime number he's computed one over that
prime number and then worked out how
many
digits before it repeats so the first
one out of the gates is 6013 and shanks
is claiming after 5001 digits its
reciprocal will repeat so one divided by
sixty thousand and thirteen it will seem
random for five thousand and one digits
then you're like this is familiar it'll
be the same as earlier should we check
one of them yeah because on the way in
today i wrote a little bit of python
software my shank spot
which will do to this automatically so
give me a prime and i'll put it in here
and see what it says i'm going to pick
61
561
that has 405 digits what do we got
405. correct shanks and shanksbot agree
so i tell we'll do one by hand
and i'll show you what the shank spot is
doing and that'll show us what the worst
case scenario can be okay so we'll start
with the prime seven
which means the reciprocal of that prime
is one over seven and this means one
divided by seven or in primary school
terms how many times does seven go into
one so let's do it as a long division so
here you've got your dividend that's the
number going into it and here you've got
the number you're you're
dividing it into so it's 7 into 1. now
the issue is 7 does not go into 1
because
this is not very groundbreaking 7 is
bigger than 1. we have a problem however
we can try and work out what fraction of
it is going to go in and so actually
while 7 doesn't go into 1 0.7
does go into 1. so if i say
0.7
goes into 1
once
that's the same as saying 7 goes into 1
0 point once
so what we're saying is 7 goes into 1
once but it's got a leftover 0.3 so what
we do now is we're going to put our
leftover down here what we've done is
we've said if you've got 1.0
and you put in 0.7 what you're left with
is
0.3 and now we're going to repeat that
implied are all these extra zeros right
because there's infinitely many of these
which is very convenient we just need to
know now we've already covered this bit
how many times seven goes into that and
now we're like okay
we can't do seven doesn't go into point
three point seven doesn't go to point
three but point zero seven does and so
you go how many times does point zero
seven go in
well
four times point zero seven is zero
point two eight
and that's four times it so we put it up
here and then we subtract that off and
we've got
0.020 now at this point
we actually don't need to write in all
these zeros every single time all we
really care about is the 2 and the 0
after it there right and so we go how
many times does 7 go into 20 well it
goes in twice it's 14.
put the 2 up there
subtract that off we get
6.
now we can add on one of these extra
spare zeros which they're infinitely
many seven goes into 50
that's eight times put the eight up
there subtract that off it's four now
it's 40. seven goes into
uh 35 five times put the five up there
and all i'm doing is the same logic as
before but now it's just a bit more
algorithmic it's a bit more
straightforward 49
7
1. ah
that's familiar that's what we had
before and so now actually we've got
exactly the same situation down here
where now
with seven going into ten then before i
was faffing around with the point sevens
basically what i'll say is seven goes
into ten once that's seven it's got a
remainder of three the one would go up
there as you can see we've now got
exactly the same here 30 would have 28
underneath we'll put another 4 there and
soon as we hit here
that
is exactly the same as what we started
with here 1 and a 0. and so this
takes us back there
in theory it you know it's carrying on
down here but because we've got exactly
the same situation
all these steps will follow in the same
order every single time which is why
seven repeats after one four two
eight five seven and that's six digits
that's when it hits this infinite loop
will all primes hit an infinite loop
like this though
yes
and let's do let's do a slightly bigger
one
and we'll be able to see why it has to
happen eventually
so brady here's what we're going to do
we're going to try and find the
reciprocal of a bigger prime
let's keep it to two digits what would
you like
um
23. 23 that is a prime we're gonna do a
long division and we're gonna divide it
into one now as you may have noticed
with sevens
each time i have a result i'm trying to
work out what multiple of the dividend
goes into it so in this case straight
out of the gates one point we have to
start putting some zeros on it doesn't
go into one doesn't go into ten does go
into a hundred you're like well how many
times yeah i think probably four
and you're like and four times that is
going to be
92 and then we did that four times so
this is actually our answer 0.04 we're
just trying to find
a number in the 23 times table
that
is
the biggest but not bigger than whatever
our remainder is at the time so what i'm
actually going to do over here i'm going
to write out my 23 times table that's
okay so 1 times 23 is 23
2 times 23 is we just double that 46.
3 times 23 is add those together
69.
4 times 3 is just double what two times
was so that's 92 which is what one we've
already used there seven times is add
three and four together
so nine and two is eleven
six nine is fifteen is one or sixteen
wouldn't it just be easier to add 23 to
that
or you could just add 23 to the previous
one okay i'm going to be i'm going to be
honest pretty you're absolutely right
and what i'm actually doing is um
because i've done this on a much much
bigger scale when calculating uh pi by
hand i've gotten used i was doing this
for like 20 digit numbers right and so
i've just gotten in this formula you're
right i got so obsessed with my silly
way of doing it
that i didn't stop and think is there a
better way
let's carry one
okay there it is cool and if we add 23
again we'd be up to 230 that's that's
ten times okay so this is going to speed
up filling it in a lot then if we
subtract that off that's eight
okay so now
uh it doesn't go into eight
it does go into 80.
69 is the biggest one we're going to
have and that's the 3.
subtract that off we're left with 11
doesn't go into 11 110 yeah 92
and that's four times before it there
we subtract this off that's going to be
18 doesn't go into 18 180 yes that's
going to be 161 is the next biggest one
seven times as you can see once you get
to the swing of this 19
190
eight times
subtract that off
six so now what we're looking for
is the first time 60 yeah 46
twice
the first time we have a point where
this
remainder
is one we've seen before so we're at 14
now
and we've never seen 14 before so i've
got to do 14 and it's going to be 138.
that gives us a remainder of this time
just 2. so
we've seen 2 before we haven't so the
numbers we care about are the top ones
which are the remainders each time so so
far we've seen
100 we've had 80 we've had 110 we've had
180 we've had 190 we've had 60 we've had
140 well now we've had 200. then we said
that 200 is
184 is eight times putting that up there
remainder here is 16. have we seen 160
before
no we haven't so now we keep going now
the question becomes
how long can we keep going and each time
we go we add one more here
until we have to hit a repeat well in
this case ignoring the padding zeros if
we just take the non-zero bit that's
actually 1 8 11 18 19 6 14
2
those that can't be bigger than 23
because if it was bigger than 23 we
would have just picked a bigger number
underneath and taken off one more lot of
it so the remainder ignoring the zeros
is always smaller than 23. so it can't
be zero
it can't be 23 but it can be any of the
numbers in between all the way up to 22
can appear in here that may not all
appear in there we may hit a loop point
before we get there or they may all
appear in there somewhere and if we just
redid this as n
then the number of options before it is
n minus one and so that's your worst
case scenario is it's going to take n
minus 1 steps once we've done that
we've used every single one the next one
has to be one we've used before we'll
hit a loop point so funnily enough we
brought the shanks chart we see here 60
017 that was as bad as it gets that was
sixty thousand and sixteen digits so it
hit every single one of them before
it finally repeated whereas the one
before it only hit five thousand it hit
like what's that like you know less than
ten percent of the possible values
before it hit a loop point
surely shanks wasn't doing this for all
those you know what i don't think he was
because
partly because
this takes a really long time and you
can see me doing it the first thing
you've got to do is you've got to
generate your table and then you've got
to go through and do this and as you can
see the way i'm doing it takes up a lot
of paper and for a small number and for
a small number and what you can do when
you get here so i've done a little long
division of my time what what we did was
we you want printed paper with squares
on it so everything stays lined up and
then when you get here you copy it up
and you can then you do another stripe
and then you copy it up and you do
another stripe but you're still going a
long way that way and you can't imagine
he went
60 016 digits in that direction that's
one clue he didn't do it this way the
other clue is the type of mistakes he
made here he thought it repeated every
30 525 and he corrected it to 61 050
which is exactly twice what he thought
he had if you look at all these
corrections he's always either doubling
or halfing it which makes me think he's
got a technique that probably involves
powers of two or something or some steps
of halving and sometimes he's done one
too many or one too few and that's what
he's corrected so that kind of
systematic error
leads me to believe he wasn't doing it
this way he had another way of doing it
he died in 1882 so this is like three
years before he died he's still sending
in he's up to primes up to 110 000. so
where did he get to on this one oh
there's a note at the end note we may
hear remark that by means of our table
we can readily find the number of
figures in the period of the reciprocals
of a composite number not having any
higher factors than a hundred and ten
thousand so he's basically said these
are useful because you can use the
reciprocals of the primes to get all the
reciprocals of the composites doesn't
say why that's useful we have simply
defined the least common multiple of
several numbers of figures in the yeah
okay and he explains how to do that and
then he signs off his only practical
application for what he's done
is you can use it to find another thing
with the practical application nice i
like this guy yeah he's got i really i
like the kind of his gym imagine how
good his youtube channel would have been
ah he definitely would have had a
youtube channel oh yeah what would he
have thought of the shank bot
i think well i don't know because
if his sole goal was to find these
numbers
he would love shankbot
i feel like it was the doing
that he enjoyed and i feel like the fact
that i coded it up and shank bot just
kicks it out
without flinching
not the same one last question because i
know you've been doing a lot of research
into him was he married yeah
yeah and his wife survived him by a good
uh pretty much two decades yeah
so he was like every morning's like
morning honey i'm off to work and by
work you just walk upstairs
start doing calculations like oh another
another hard day in the office
there are some obvious follow-on
questions that you could have at this
point you could ask yourself how do you
take the reciprocals
at least the length of the repeating
part of the reciprocals of the primes
and use it to work out the repeating
part the reciprocals of composites which
is what shanks put in there as a little
note you can also ask yourself what's
special about the numbers like seven
that use every single one of these
before they get back to where they
started and it it turns out it's
something called you've got a thing
called a primitive root so prime numbers
don't have factors but they can't have
primitive roots which involves doing
powers of things and remainders and
primes that have 10 as a primitive root
will have every single one of these pop
up
because 10's their primitive root they
go through every single one before they
get back to the first one which is why
6013 does not have 10 as a primitive
root so it only used 5001
and then 60 017 does have 10 as a
primitive route and that's why it took
the took that long it used every single
one before i got back to where i started
and there's a thing called a reptender
prime um which also tells you the ones
that have this incredible property so if
people want to look into it there's a
lot more fun for me however
all about the long division
so just so i'm clear sixty thousand and
seventeen and
seven
are rep ten primes yes because they go
to the max yeah yeah yeah i will allow
that as a definition
if you like this video you're really
gonna like matt parker's new video for
pi day 2022 it's on his channel stand up
maths
and also
matt myself and keith moore from the
royal society talk more shanks on the
objectivity channel there are links here
on the screen and down in the video
description
hero yeah hero northumbrian hero
and still
world record holder for most digits of
pi
calculated by hand